So today we'll not
talk about SQL.
We'll talk about reasoning and,
particularly, reinforcement
learning for LLM reasoning.
So a high-level reasoning
could mean many, many things.
And it clearly even today
means different things
for different people,
but what I'm going
to do today in this lecture--
and also I should
mention that it's
very hard to do justice to
reasoning topics in one lecture.
This was also a
trouble that I had
for my own class
this semester, where
I was covering similar
content two weeks ago,
and I couldn't go
over everything.
But what I'm going
to do today is
to give you at least
one perspective
on some of the trends in
the field of reasoning.
And for doing
that, what we'll do
is we'll restrict ourselves
to solving math problems.
So if you're following all
the news in language models
these days, people
have been really
excited about solving technical
questions like math and coding
and scientific questions
with these models.
And one of the benchmarks
people look at, for example,
is this AIME exam, American
Invitational Mathematical
Examination.
This is an example question
from that particular exam where
you have to solve a certain
number theory question,
for instance.
And to solve this-- these
are some ground truth
solutions for it-- you have to
solve this in natural language
where you want your language
model, for instance, seeing
this question,
produce a solution
that looks like one
of those solutions
that you'll see up on the slide.
So I took these solutions from
the reference solutions that
exist for this exam, but
you would want your LLM
to be capable enough
to, one, write
a solution like this and, two,
come up with the right answer
finally.
So that's all for
the goal for today.
So what I'll do today is I'll
give you my perspective on--
or I'll organize the
material and reasoning
and, especially RL for
reasoning, in a particular way
that I particularly like.
And to do that, we'll start
off from the conventional way
or looking back at
the conventional way
of training language models.
So typically, when we train
language models or just
generally foundation
models overall,
the conventional
paradigm has been
to do next token prediction,
meaning you take your data.
You tokenize that into a string
of tokens and token inputs,
and you train the model with
a negative log likelihood loss
to predict the next token
that appears in the sequence.
So in the context
of reasoning, this
would mean you would
take the question.
You would tokenize it
into a string of tokens.
You'll take the answer, which
is from one of these reference
solutions, tokenize that
into a string of tokens,
and then train the
model to predict
this answer string conditioned
on the input question string.
Now, to start to
look at, or start
to understand why
RL matters here,
we'll start by
asking this question
of why does next token
prediction of this form
actually work?
And again, this
answering this question
will take more than--
it's an open research
question to be honest.
But one perspective of looking
at this that I particularly like
is to look at this
particular equation, which
tells you how well next token
prediction works in general.
So what is this
equation telling me?
It's telling me that if I
train a model, if I train
a particular model p theta,
which is mapping some inputs x,
like the question, to some
output y, like the answer,
this learned model is only
going to approximate the ground
truth underlying model, or
the ground truth solution,
with an error, meaning
with an error that
is shown on the slide, which
is p theta minus p star,
depending on the size of the
data that you use for training.
So if you have a
lot of data which
shows you many, many questions
and many, many answers,
then ideally this
error would be low,
and you would approximate a
very highly capable expert
at solving these questions.
But in reality, it so happens
that the amount of data
that you have for a
lot of these reasoning
problems, many other
domains as well,
you really don't have enough
data to make this bound
small enough, so
you end up learning
models that are
not approximating
human-level capabilities if you
just do next token prediction.
So there's actually
a lot of work
that exists out there which
studies the amount of data.
And one of the interesting
things that they tell you
is if you simply keep doing--
if you simply keep taking
high-quality solutions
of hard questions
from the internet,
and you train your model with
some supervised training,
some next token
prediction, you can not
do really well
because it's estimated
that you're going to run out of
high-quality data of this sort
by 2028.
And clearly, have not
gotten to a level where
you can do great research
with-- or these models,
can just replace human
researchers, for instance.
This also happens
in other domains,
like for instance, in robotics
and embodied AI where, again,
data is very
limited, which means
that if you just simply rely
on next token prediction
alone, you'll not be able to get
the ground truth expert level
capability in your
model of sorts.
So just to give you
a concrete example,
if you just train
models on current data,
and you ask them to solve
this very interesting question
from IMO 2021,
presumably this question
exists in the training sets
of one of these models.
But if you ask GPT or OpenAI
family of models to solve this,
they're going to give you
a solution that looks very
sensible in these settings.
So they're going to
produce solutions
that look quite like a solution
that a human expert would have
written, except that
they end up missing
the logic behind the answer.
So in this particular question,
if you need to prove that
inequality that you
see up on the slide,
you cannot really go out there
and start to look at individual
terms of that expression.
You have to think about
the whole summation
as a whole and these models.
This is, I think, from
an O series model--
I think O1 that I
got the solution.
It starts to look at
individual terms, for instance,
and ends up asserting
its solution at the end.
But it really does not
realize that it's actually
making a mistake and
does not correct it.
So really, what
ends up happening
with these current supervised
training paradigms, when
you think about
reasoning, is that they're
going to produce a
solution that looks very
much like a legitimate
solution that you
could have written on an exam.
It's just that solution
ends up being wrong,
and the logical content of that
solution is not quite correct.
And that's precisely something
that RL tries to fix.
And I'll hopefully
try to show you
some examples today
of what kind of RL
techniques come to
rescue in that setting.
So in today's
lecture, I guess we'll
talk about RL for reasoning.
I roughly characterized
this in two parts,
or I broke this
down into two parts.
And these two parts
are based on timeline.
So it's based on stuff that
came before the DeepSeek-R1
family of models came out.
How many of you know what the
DeepSeek R1 model is actually?
I'm just curious-- or have seen
it, have played around with it?
It's a model that
was released, which
is from a company in China
named DeepSeek, which
is really, really
good at solving
a lot of these competition math
problems or competition coding
problems.
It's in a similar
vein, a similar style
of model as the OpenAI
series of models,
or some of these thinking
models that exist out there,
like the Gemini thinking
model or Claude Sonnet
thinking version, et cetera.
So these are models
of the same family.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to talk about
techniques that
came before these models came
out, which is early 2025-- so
January 2025-- and some
techniques that have become
much more prominent
in the community
after these models came out.
So the first part
of my lecture will
be based on these
classical techniques
that I'm going to talk about.
And I'll talk about
techniques that rely
on some form of imitation
learning, which I'm guessing
has been covered in the class.
We'll talk about
some techniques that
look like offline
reinforcement learning,
and I'll talk about
some techniques
that look like online
reinforcement learning.
This is my characterization
of this whole space.
In general, there's
a lot of literature
that has been coming
out, so I'll probably
miss out on some
of them, but this
is roughly a
characterization that I think
makes sense to think about.
And after that,
I'm going to talk
about some modern extensions
of these techniques
into this thinking model
territory, where we'll
talk about how can you take
some of these techniques
that people have built
before early 2025?
And think about
using them to train
thinking models that have been
doing really amazing right now.
And there's some very
interesting things
that need to change when you go
from the first on the left hand
side to the right hand side
in this particular setting.
So I guess I already talked
about the problem setup,
but let me just quickly go
into a little bit of a detail
and connect back
to RL terminology.
So we're going to
consider reasoning.
And in this particular setting
as I described earlier,
you will be given a problem
in natural language,
and you have to write a
solution in natural language.
So what we can do when you think
about this in the context of RL
from an RL person's
lens, is you can
think of this whole
problem solving as an MDP,
as a Markov Decision Process.
And to do that,
what you can do is
you can think of
the string of tokens
that exist in the--
or string of words
that exist in the
question as sort
of an initial state of your MDP.
So it's the initial state
that your agent or your policy
is going to start from when
it starts to act in the world.
You can think of the solution
that the model produces
as being broken down
into a sequence of steps,
and these steps could correspond
to actions, for example.
So you can think
of it as there's
a model, which takes as input
this initial state, which
is the problem.
It, one by one, takes
in a bunch of actions
which are these
steps, and at the end
ends up with a
particular answer.
So in this particular
setting, that answer
is represented in this
box that you see up there.
And the answer is 8.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to reward the model
with a sparse reward of plus 1
if this answer ends up being
correct, and a reward of 0
if this answer does not
end up being correct.
So the real Markov decision
process here is state.
I'm going to a
sequence of actions
and going to a termination
bit where the model produces
an answer and you get a
reward at the end of it
if the particular answer
is correct or not.
So in RL terminology, this is
a lot like a sparse reward MDP
with a deterministic dynamics.
What do I mean by this?
Basically, there's no
external environment
in this whole process of
producing these steps.
There's no external environment
that gives you a next state.
All you are seeing is the
initial state and these actions
one by ond, which tell you that
the next state of the problem.
So I'll just draw on the
board because I think--
so this is your initial state.
Your model takes as action,
the particular step.
The first step of
the problem, it
gets to state S1,
which is nothing
but the string of
tokens in S0 and S0
concatenated with each other.
So that's all S1 is.
It produces the next
state A1 or next--
it takes the next step A1 or
next action A1 goes to S2.
And your next state
S2 is just S0, A0, A1
concatenated with each other
until you hit the final answer.
So you do this multiple times.
You hit the final answer.
Your model produces some
answer-- let's say 8.
You get a reward
which is based on
whether 8 is equal to the
ground truth answer or not.
So you get a reward of r
of 8 comma ground truth.
This is either plus 1 or 0.
That's your MDP that
you're operating in.
So that's a very good question.
So the actions here
could be infinity.
There are infinitely
many actions.
But unlike having-- unlike
continuous control where
you have a fixed dimension
vector of continuous values,
which are also infinite, you
have a variable length string
of tokens which are
discrete, but then there
could be many of them.
So the question is,
what about questions
where the answer is a proof or
not a final numerical value?
That's a very good question.
I think we as a
community haven't
figured out the right set of
techniques for such problems.
So that's why we started off
with competition problems
where there is a sort of a
deterministic final answer
in some ways.
So we'll assume for
now that we have
a deterministic final
answer we'll end with.
Yeah, so the question,
is there a risk
that we get to the right answer,
but we take suboptimal steps?
There is.
And I'm going to be talking
about that in this lecture
actually.
Yeah.
So that's a basic reasoning
MDP or a language.
MDP, you can pose for
studying reasoning problems
in this particular setting,
and at least something
that I'm going to be sticking
to in this particular lecture.
So we'll start with
studying some classical RL
methods for reasoning.
And what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to cover one of my
papers from NeurIPS 2024
that you see on the slide.
This is the first bullet point.
And why am I
covering that paper?
It's not because
this paper invented
a lot of the techniques, but
because this paper actually
did a lot of interesting
empirical analysis
of a lot of the
methods that exist out
there to understand
why something works
and why something fails.
So it's just a nice way
to get a conceptual model,
at least in my opinion,
about all the techniques
and the classical
reasoning space with RL.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to try to understand
how different methods--
or how RL methods for
training for reasoning
behave when we train them on
different amounts of data.
So we're going to do what
we call a data scaling
analysis in this particular
segment of the talk.
So the basic setup
here would be,
I'm going to build
algorithms that
can be used to train reasoning
models on a data set.
This data set will
consist of some problems
or these initial states that
I described to you earlier.
And we'll assume access
to some Oracle solutions
because we need a way to
check the ground truth
answer because that defines
the reward function.
So we have a data set of
problems and solutions
that we're going to
be training with.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to try to understand
different classes of methods
by evaluating how well
they do when we train them
on different amounts of
problems and solution pairs
that this data set gives us.
So there's three
axes we're going
to look at when we
think about training
these methods on this data.
We can train them with
potentially ground truth answers
on multiple questions.
So we can take this data set
of problems and solutions
and train the model to
produce the solution, given
the question, like, what
supervised fine tuning
or imitation learning does.
So we can just do imitation
learning on top of this data.
We'll introduce a new method
that we call rejection fine
tuning, which trains on many
correct solutions for a given
answer.
So I'm going to write
this method out here,
and that'll be clear for you.
So what you're going to do is
you're going to take a model
pi of y given x.
We'll take a question
x from my data set.
So this is my
question or problem.
So this is my initial state.
This is my solution
which consists
of a sequence of actions.
What I'm going to do now is I'm
going to take these questions
and sample multiple solutions
from my particular model,
from my current model
that I want to train
in this particular setting.
So I have a model pi theta.
I'm going to sample multiple
solutions conditioned
on the question, given
this particular model.
So this is my model I'm
training, the initial model.
This is the data set.
I'm going to sample
multiple solution traces.
What I'm going to do now is
I'm going to take these traces,
evaluate the rewards
on each of them.
So I'm going to evaluate
r of Y1, r of Y2, r of Yn.
Why can I do this?
Because I have this
question in my data set
which means I have a
ground truth answer,
y star, for this question
in my data set as well.
Ground truth answer
for x question.
And what I can do
is I can simply
match whether multiple traces
or multiple trajectories
sampled from my policy pi theta
end up in the right answer
or not by checking whether the
final number was correct or not.
So what I'm doing here is
I'm taking my initial model,
sampling a bunch of
traces, or rolling it out
in my environment, which is
simply producing solutions
from this model
for each question
and evaluating the rewards
against the ground truth answer.
Now, what I do is I take
this particular set of Y1
to Yn's I produced, and I
retain only those ones which
ended up in the right answer.
So I take the set s of
Y1 to Yn, and I filter
it to get some filtered set.
Let's call it's s
tilde, which consists
of Ys, so Yj, such
that the reward is 1,
meaning these solutions
ended up at the right answer.
Does this procedure
make sense to people?
OK.
And what I'm going
to do now is now
I have a bunch of traces
or a bunch of trajectories
that ended up at the
right answer, which
means they're successful.
So what I can do is I can simply
try to train my model pi theta
to imitate these trajectories.
So I can train pi theta
to imitate S tilde.
So I'm just going to
write it down here again.
So my algorithm looks like
this for iteration 1 to some t
that I can choose
however I want.
So step one is sample Y1
to n from pi theta of dot
given x question.
The second step is
filter and generate
s tilde, which consists
of correct Y's only.
And the third step is, do
imitation or do BC or SFP,
depending upon whatever
terminology you like--
you can call that--
on s tilde.
So you're training
the model now by theta
to produce only the
Y's that were correct.
So that's this
particular approach.
So this approach
is what is called
rejection fine tuning or RFP.
And that's why you see
it on the horizontal axis
up there where what
you're doing now
is you're going to
produce many solutions
and try to filter for correct
ones and train on them again.
What happens now
is you're rejecting
the ones that were wrong,
hence the word rejection.
And fine tuning just stands
for fine tuning, so RFT
or rejection fine tuning.
The nice property
about this approach
is it's not actually, asking
you for Oracle solutions
that a human wrote.
All it asks for is solutions
that your model can produce,
which ended up being correct.
So these are on-policy
rollouts that
are sampled from your policy.
And you're simply
filtering for correctness,
which you can because you know
what the reward function looks
like.
And the third axis
here is actually
full-blown
reinforcement learning
where, in RL when
we train on data,
we don't really
need the data to be
high-quality or high-rewarding.
You talked about offline RL.
That's on your homework.
You can learn from
suboptimal data,
data that does not succeed.
And so you can also think
about the third axis in all
of these methods
as methods which
train on incorrect
solutions or learn
from traces or rollouts
that did not succeed,
that attained a reward of 0.
So I'm just going
to call them RL.
So there are these three
different axis along which
you can train methods.
You can scale your data.
You can scale your model
bandwidth, number of questions
and Oracle solutions,
SFT, number of questions
and correct solutions by
filtering or rejection, which
is called Rejection
Fine Tuning, or RFP,
and just training on
any kind of data, which
is reinforcement learning.
So what I'm going to
do in this lecture
is we'll talk about how these
different methods actually
behave in practice,
and that'll give us
a sense of what to
use in what case.
So the question is, are we
forcing the model to come up
with overly verbose answers?
So here we are not really--
so the short answer is no
because here we are not really
encouraging verbosity at all.
All we're doing is we're
simply sampling multiple traces
from a model and training
the model to find answers--
train the model to closley
mimic traces, which ended up
being successful in some way.
So if the traces that
end up being successful
are those that actually need
more space to be verbose,
then it's going to
incentivize you to be verbose.
But if the questions
that end up succeeding
are not those-- or the
traces that end up succeeding
are not the ones that end
up needing to be verbose,
then it's going to
not incentivize it.
So imagine that, let's
say, the question
is 2 plus 2 is equal
to question mark.
Maybe one of the traces
gets you an answer of 4.
And there are some
traces which are
going to do this, which
are going to count 2 plus 2
in 10 different ways.
But most of the traces
write down 4 right away.
Then what you're going
to do in this process
is you're going to find
traces which end up with a 4
right away, and you're going to
train them all to produce four
right away as the next token.
So it's not necessarily
going to happen that way.
So the question is if the
method got the correct answer
with the wrong approach, then
you're incentivizing the model
to learn that.
And the answer is
yes, and that's
why we'll see how these things
behave in empirical results.
That's the next
part of the talk.
Yeah, so the question
is, would the data set
be biased towards easy problems?
The short answer is, it
does, yes, in some way.
But the practical
answer for this question
is, well, in these cases,
what you're going to do
is you're going to
potentially start
with training the model on
top of Oracle Data or Oracle
question answer
pairs, first with SFT,
the first axis that goes up,
and then do rejection fine
tuning on top of it.
So the model has
some capability now
to produce some answers
for those questions,
and then you'll start doing it.
Great, so this was
actually one of the slides
which took me a long time
even in my lecture back then.
But a lot of the
slides from here
on are actually talking about
properties of these methods
actually.
So the first thing
we're going to look at
is how does SFT behave?
So training your
model with imitation
learning on correct
answers, given
questions that some human wrote.
So when we're doing this work
we looked at two benchmarks
named GSM8K and MATH.
These benchmarks now
are fully solved.
So it doesn't make sense to,
going forward, benchmark methods
on these benchmarks.
But back then in 2024-- this
was a year ago exactly--
these benchmarks were very
sort of representative
of useful methods.
So what we tried to do
in this particular slide
is we are trying to see
how well SFT behaves
and comparing it
to-- and we're trying
to compare it to RFP, or
Rejection Fine Tuning,
that I described to you.
We do that on top
of multiple models,
and here I'm showing you one
result on top of the DeepSeek V2
model.
That was one of the best math
models back at that time.
And what I'm plotting here is
I'm plotting the average test
error of these model after fine
tuning with these SFT and RFP
methods as a function of how
much data we run fine tuning on.
So the more the data, the ideal.
And the picture is you
will get lower error,
and you should be able to
actually get better accuracy
because you have more data, more
coverage of questions like that.
So that indeed does happen.
So you do find that
error goes down
as you scale up the
amount of questions
in both of these settings.
But clearly, the
error does not go down
at a very fast rate,
meaning it so turns out
that the test error, if you
try to approximate the closest
function to this
particular curve,
it'll be the function that
looks like D to the minus 0.15
or D to the minus 0.05.
So this particular curve
that you're seeing,
these are empirical
measurements.
But if I try to fit
a smooth curve to it
as a function of
the data set size,
that the exponent is going
to be a very small number.
Ideally, you would want this
exponent to be really large,
like, D to the minus
1/2, for instance,
because this curve will
go down very quickly.
And with a reasonable
amount of data,
you're going to be succeeding
at the particular problem--
at this particular data set.
But that doesn't
happen in this case.
So one of the goals
that we then could
have for a lot of these
reasoning methods and RL
methods for reasoning
is to push this curve
as much as possible towards the
left and towards the x-axis.
So push them down
and towards the left.
And the first result
we saw to that extent
was the fact that rejection
fine tuning or training
on your own data, on your
own correct solutions,
actually gets you a
much better test error.
So you find that you can get the
same test error on both of these
benchmarks with RFP, as you
could do with 2x the number
of questions and 2x the number
of human-written solutions
for SFT.
So what this tells you at a
high level is that on-policy
imitation, learning, sampling
from your policy and imitating
the correct answers can be
2x more efficient in this
particular setting, compared
to SFT alone or off-policy SFT
or just imitation
learning alone.
OK, great.
So that's the first result,
first takeaway to have here.
But it so turns out
that if you simply
keep doing this
over and over, it's
not going to give you the best
possible policy or the best
possible model.
So if you simply keep scaling
up SFT on policy data,
what do I mean by scaling it up?
I mean you increase this value
of n that you see up here.
So you just sample tons
and tons of solutions
and pick the correct
ones and just start
to do BC on all of them.
Turns out that that recipe
does not actually work.
So what happens is on-policy
imitation learning ends
up hurting generalization
if you do too much of it.
And to show a result
for it, I'm going
to show you a plot here,
which is showing the test
performance, so the same plot.
But now the x-axis is the
number of correct answers
you get in this filtered
set that I was describing
to you earlier per question.
So you can scale it up for
how much ever you want.
The size of s tilde multiplied
by a constant factor
is shown on the
x-axis, and we're
plotting the performance of the
resulting RFP trained model.
The interesting
thing to notice here
is that, initially,
your error goes down.
So as you do more
and more correct
solution traces, as you
generate more and more
of these correct
solution traces,
your error goes down,
as you see initially.
But then beyond a
point, your error
starts to go up in this
particular setting.
So you find that,
beyond a point,
you get diminishing returns.
And there's no
way you can simply
generate more solutions
from your policy,
mimic them, and get
better performance.
And in fact, the error even goes
up on some of these data sets
that you see up here.
[INAUDIBLE]
You can think of it as S--
the size of S tilde.
It's the number of
correct solutions
you retain per question.
So the question was,
what is the x-axis?
The x-axis is number of S tilde.
For each S.
So the plot it's basically,
S tilde times 8K in the plot
because that's the number of
prompts that you see up here.
But yeah, it's just
a constant multiplier
which stays same for all the
points on that particular plot.
So that's a great question.
So the question is, when you
scale S tilde, which is for RFP,
do you do deduplication?
The answer is yes.
And I actually removed
that detail from my slide
because I thought it
would be too much details.
But since you asked
it, the answer
is yes, you would often--
when you do this process,
you would often
deduplicate S tildes.
There's a lot of
mechanisms for it.
People can do just edit
distance-based rejection
as well.
So keep the sample more than n.
So one of the recipes people do
is sample more than n, like, 2n,
and retain the n of them, which
actually seem to be maximally
diverse.
That's something people
do a lot of times.
So yeah, you do
that kind of thing.
Great, OK.
So what this tells
us at a high level
is that fitting on
self-generated data
on a limited number
of initial states
actually hurts
generalization of the model.
So if you recall the
picture that I drew earlier,
which I erased, where there was
an S0, and your model took an A0
and went to S1, you can think
of this as basically training
on a set of S0 and
evaluating on a new set,
on a new test problem.
And turns out that if you train
too much on a particular set
of S naughts in
this particular way,
you end up hitting
the generalization
bottleneck in that setting.
OK, so why does this happen?
And this is the picture that
I'm going to talk about.
And I'll connect it to some
of the interesting concepts
that we know in imitation
learning right now,
which is this picture
of spurious steps.
So yeah, so what
we're going to do
is we'll move away a
little bit from examples
and look at pictures.
And what we'll do is
we'll plot these pictures,
as I was describing
to you earlier,
as this little
trajectory in an MDP.
So you have prompts
as initial states,
and you're producing
these steps one by one.
They take you to next states.
And then eventually, you
end up at the answer.
So happens that when you sample
a lot from your own model
and train on it on
policy, like, you
sample from your
policy and train
on it, you'll often
find that there
are some of these traces which
end up having steps which
are spurious in nature, steps
which actually are incorrect,
but they just somehow don't
affect the model's generation.
So I'm going to
show you an example.
But basically, these are steps
which would take you to a regime
where you're maybe doing
a wrong calculation.
Somehow, you get there.
Maybe on this
particular trace when
you're sampling
from your model, you
end up do recovering
from these traces.
So you end up with
the correct answer.
But maybe in reality, these
traces are actually harmful.
So just to give you
an example, let's say
this is a little
arithmetic problem.
It's from this GSM8K data set.
One interesting
example we found,
which was the most stark example
of this particular issue,
was there's a solution
from the model which
does some calculation.
Then it says that the total
amount of money needed
is like, 100 times
2, which is 200,
and it reverses its
calculation in the next line.
So the true calculation is 100
by 2, but it ends up saying 200
and then goes to
100 by 2 right away.
So what ends up happening
is this particular step that
exists in the middle, where it's
doing 200, is a spurious step.
It's a step that is not needed.
It's an incorrect step that
exists in the solution.
You end up still
at the right answer
in this particular
rollout, but this step
shouldn't be there in reality
in that particular setting.
So that's a spurious step
in this particular set.
So the question is the
step is always a sentence.
For now, you can
imagine it's always
a sentence in this
particular setting.
There's no universally
agreed upon definition to it.
So this is a very--
I guess in the second
part of my talk,
I'm going to show you some
examples where the step is not
at all a sentence.
It's a full block of things.
So yeah, that's
a great question.
So the question is, "Is this the
main cause of increase in error?
And can you not measure
it in some way?"
So it turns out that
the answer to both
is, yes, it's one of the main
causes for increase in error.
Can you measure it in some way?
At least normal notions
of fitting the data
won't tell you this.
That's a great question.
So the question is, "Can we
associate the overfitting
problem to this?"
So you can actually
measure this.
In the paper, we
did measure this.
We measured the amount of
spurious steps that you see,
and it grows on over time.
Obviously, I cannot give you
a proof that this is the only
cause.
I can give you proof that
this should be a problem.
I cannot give you a proof
that this is the only problem,
but this is one of the
big problems that you see.
So the question is, "How do
you find out if it's a spurious
step?"
In our experiments, we do
it in a particular way,
and that also dictates
a lot of methodologies
that I'm going to
show you in a second.
So this particular method--
so the question is, "Do you
sample entire trajectories?"
This particular method
samples entire trajectories.
You can sample a
parts of trajectories
if you want it to
be, but I think
it needs some advanced
machinery that I
think can be done based on
what I'm going to talk about
in the next slide.
That's a great question.
So the question is, "Do you
overfit to a certain class
of methods that got
to the right answer?"
In a way, the answer is, at a
high level, yes, with the caveat
that I don't know how to
define what a method means.
So you can call a method that--
so just seeing this
example, one can
say that the calculation
of 100 times 2
is a methodological phenomenon
that the model wants
to do to be able to
then succeed and then
realize that it was wrong.
You can also say that
really, the method here
is nothing but just doing
a bunch of arithmetic,
so it really depends on
what you define that.
And I think it's a semantic
question at that point.
But yeah, so from a very
symbolic perspective,
one can say that there are a set
of tokens that maybe still lead
you to the right answer
on the training set,
but may not actually help you do
the right thing on the test set,
on a test problem.
So this is very similar to the
problem of causal confusion
in imitation learning actually.
I'm not sure if
causal confusion--
OK, OK, OK, never mind.
But basically
there's this problem
of if you produce
a bunch of stuff
in your policy, that might be
bad, like these spurious steps,
you might just not
learn to imitate
the expert in the
right way possible.
So maybe you actually end
up at the right answer,
but you're learning these
incorrect associations.
That's basically the gist of
this problem of causal confusion
that people in
imitation learning
know a lot about actually,
OK, so how can we address this?
And that's where RL
comes in, and that's
the third axis of
using incorrect data
or incorrect rollouts
for learning.
The simple idea
is, as many of you
already asked questions
about, assigning some notion
of a credit to a step.
So if I can understand what is
the utility of every single step
or every single state
that my policy generates,
then I can somehow
use that notion
to filter off these bad kinds
of solutions in some way.
So that's exactly what we
do, or what RL for reasoning
tries to do at a
high level as well.
So identifying
these spurious steps
and eliminating
them in some way.
So the way to do this is the
following-- and this ties
back to a lot of concepts of
value functions and advantage
functions that many of you
are probably familiar with.
So I'm going to start
with an illustration,
and then I'll write down the
exact math for what this means.
So let's say I gave you
a particular rollout
or a particular trace.
So again, starting
from a prompt,
adding these steps
or actions and going
to a final answer, which maybe
ended up being incorrect,
so it's shown as a red dot.
What I can do now is I can try
to identify whether a step is
spurious or not by taking
these particular prefixes,
or taking these particular
states that were basically
concatenating all
the tokens so far,
and doing what you can think
of as rollouts in a way.
So I can ask some model to try
to complete the solution, given
a prefix of a
generated solution.
So for example, in
this particular setting
that you see on the slide,
I have kept the first three
steps the same.
And I'm asking a separate model
or a separate rollout policy
to try to complete the solution,
given this particular prefix.
So if I do this, and let's say
the rollout ends up succeeding--
so many of these rollouts
end up at the right answer--
then, likely, the prefix was
not too bad because, clearly,
for this particular
rollout policy,
it did not end up
affecting any of
its problem-solving abilities.
On the other hand,
let's say if I ended up
at a totally wrong answer,
conditioned on the prefix
that you see up here, clearly,
something is not OK here.
And clearly, there's something
wrong with the prefix
that you're seeing up
here because your rollout
policy could not at all succeed,
conditioned on that prefix, even
after doing many
possible rollouts.
And if I ended up succeeding
sometimes and sometimes not,
maybe there's still some issue.
Maybe it's not the best
thing you can have,
but at least it's
slightly better
than always failing that you
see up here, for instance.
So this basic principle of
doing rollouts and estimating
some notion of expected
success in the future
can tell you
something about what
is wrong with the current
prefix that you are particularly
operating at.
This is also very similar to a
value function because this is
basically computing the expected
future 01 reward that my rollout
policy, that this orange policy
gets when it acts in this
particular MDP.
So the question is-- the
spurious step on the previous
slide--
"IS that actually
irrelevant or Incorrect?"
Or irrelevant slash--
I mean, it's incorrect
purely because--
or OK, the step is not
incorrect in its own right,
but it is irrelevant a way.
Imagine for a second that
if you pass to a language
model a million
irrelevant tokens
and ask it to dig out the
information that actually
matters, that can be a
challenging problem on a test
set.
So that's why, even if
a step is irrelevant,
it can be a problem
for the model.
OK.
So we did these rollouts.
We computed the expected value
of how many times can I succeed?
And that resembles
something that looks
like a value function of sorts.
And why is it a value function?
Because if you write this
down in a bit of math--
so let's say if I define the
problem or the initial state
as x, each of these steps
as Y1's to Yn's So I
guess there's a bit of a
notation mismatch here Y1
to Yn's are independent rollout.
Here, the Yi's I'm showing
are basically each step
or each action that you take.
So if you define a quantity
that looks like the following,
it's basically a Q function.
So what is this quantity?
It's telling you the Q value
for your particular rollout
policy, pi tilde.
So the policy which is trying
to complete the solution,
rollout policy pi tilde.
I'm computing its Q value at a
given state given by the initial
state and the prefix
of the solution so far,
and given an action, which
is the current step that
your policy adds, I can define
the Q value here as the expected
long-term reward, meaning
the expected 01 reward,
that I get under
my rollout policy.
If I start by executing--
if I start by getting
actions I plus 1 to L
from this rollout policy.
So what's the Q function?
A Q function, just
to recall, Q pi--
I guess, it's subscript pi.
Q pi of s,a is basically nothing
but R of s,a, or, I guess,
depends upon how you write this.
But it's basically the expected
discounted reward that you get,
starting from P equal to
0 to, let's say, infinity
in general, conditioned
on S0 being S
and A0 being A. This is the
definition of a Q function.
In this particular
setting, we are
assuming discount factor is 1.
So gamma is set to exactly 1.
And the reward that you
get is only at termination,
so there's 0000 until you end
up hitting the final answer.
So that's why you see there's
only one expectation up there.
And this expectation is
computed under policy pi.
So you roll this policy
pi out from there on.
There's one minor detail here.
You typically have R of s,a plus
this thing because you roll out
the policy from the next step,
and you sum up the reward
at the current state.
In this case, it doesn't matter
because r of s,a is equal to 0.
You only get a
reward at the end.
Gamma is set to 1.
So essentially, the thing
that you see up here
is essentially an
expected future reward,
starting from a
given prefix, which
is the state at a given
step, which is the action.
And the rollout is
performed under pi tilde
that you see up here.
So the question is, "Would you
use the same policy to roll out
those other trajectories?"
So in principle, this
equation that I wrote
is agnostic of which policy
you use to do the rollout.
So there's been actually no--
so I have a belief
about this answer,
about this particular
choice of the policy.
So in my opinion, the policy
that you're doing rollouts
with should be a
different policy,
compared to the current
one, otherwise, it
can fail in the same way.
There's some work
in literature which
argues that even
using the same policy
can actually be good enough.
I think we haven't seen an
apples-to-apples comparison,
given the scale of
experiments, which definitively
shows one way or the other.
I think most of the evidence
that exists right now points
towards the benefits from
having a different policy
because that makes sense also.
But I think there's a part
of the community, especially
the NLP community, which
does it using the same policy
and finds it to work
reasonably fine.
That's a great question.
So the question is, "This
similar to trajectory stitching
and advantage weights?"
So turns out that the
answer is exactly, yes.
It is very related to that.
I don't think I have a
discussion of this stitching
angle in my slides
because I think it would
have been a bit too technical.
But yeah, if you check the
paper, you will find exactly.
It talks about stitching
in this particular setting,
and it's very related concepts.
So yeah, think of it that way.
OK, great.
So this is the definition
of a Q function.
And once you've defined
this Q function,
it turns out that you can use
this Q function to now tell you
whether steps are spurious
or not or are good
or not, in the same way as
defining advantages would
have done.
So I'm pretty sure
you talked about
advantage-weighted regression
as an offline RL method.
I'm going to do something
very similar to that,
but just to spend one minute on
the definition of the advantage
here.
So the advantage function
typically means q s,a minus V
of s that you
probably talked about.
So a of s,a under a given policy
is Q pi I of s,a minus V pi
of S.
In this particular setting,
though, the dynamics
are deterministic, and
the state is simply
a concatenation of
the previous state
with a new set of tokens
which define the step that
is added in there.
Hence, what happens is you
can define the advantage as Q
value of the prefix until step
I minus Q value of the prefix
until step I minus 1.
That serves as the same
notion of advantage
in this particular MDP.
So that's why the
definition you see up
there is Q minus Q
and not Q minus V,
but it's basically
the same thing.
So once you define
it in this way,
you can actually compute these
advantages for every step.
So you can compute advantages
by subtracting the Q values
for consecutive steps,
one from each other.
And you'll get some positive
and some negative numbers
in this particular setting.
Just really depends on how
many times can you succeed.
And once you have
these advantages,
they are a measure of how
well a particular step, how
much a particular step
contributed to your ability
to be able to succeed from
that particular prefix.
So if step two ended up
reducing the advantage,
that means your Q value at step
one was higher than Q value
after step two
has been executed,
which means step
two is probably not
that good of a step
to have in order to be
able to succeed eventually.
So a negative or a
low advantage means
it's a bad step or
of a spurious step,
and you don't want to
necessarily learn from it.
A positive advantage
means it's a good step,
and you probably want to
learn from it in some way.
So this was supposed
to answer the questions
about how do you identify
spurious steps in something.
So the question is, "Are
we fitting a Q function?"
It's a very good question.
Turns out that in
the literature,
there's been two kinds of work.
They explicitly fit a Q
function like quantity.
It's what's called-- so
in the NLP community,
this is what's called
a process reward model,
process reward model.
So I'm guessing since
you covered DPO and RHF,
you talked about
reward models which
give you a score for
particular question and answer.
This is giving you the
score for every step
and hence, scoring the process
and, hence, the word Process
Reward Model, or a PRM.
I don't necessarily think that
PRM and Q values are exactly--
or should be semantically
the same thing,
but that's what a lot of
the NLP people call this.
But yeah, you can train that.
But there's the other class
of methods which would simply
use rollouts the way I talked
to you about to estimate
advantages, and we'll
see what that means.
Yeah, that's a great question.
So the question is, how
does this help learn--
or how does this
help models learn
general problem-solving
strategies?
The rough answer is, ultimately,
what ends up happening here
is you're breaking
down the success
of a particular long trace into
successes of individual steps
that appear inside of it.
And that can be a useful
thing to because, now,
presumably your model can
realize that, OK, once ,
let's say, it has broken down a
problem into four steps or four
high-level plans, if it can also
localize which step is going
wrong, it can actually better
learn that step as opposed
to just vaguely
thinking that, OK,
a step three might be the cause
of the problem when it fails,
whereas maybe it's
actually step one.
So it helps you just
learn in a more--
so ultimately, you need to
have some data for learning,
but then this is vastly
improving your data efficiency
and so on.
Yeah.
Great.
OK, so the next
step is going to be
to use these advantages
for training,
and this is where a lot of the
methods that I talked about also
will come into picture.
So the first thing
is just going to be
to filter by advantages
that I just described.
So you can take a bunch
of traces from your model.
And I still have the
RFT algorithm here,
so I'm going to write it down
as 1 to N, sample from pi theta.
You can take this--
You can take the RFT algorithm.
You can sample from your model
and on-policy trace potentially.
You can take every
step, do these rollouts
that we talked about, use
them to estimate advantages,
and put this into
your training data set
for doing imitation
learning or SFT,
if this particular
step is correct.
So what does that mean?
That basically means that you
are taking a particular trace,
and you are checking
at a step level
whether the advantages
are positive.
Even if that particular step
comes from an incorrect solution
trace, you're going to put
that into your training
data set if that step itself
gives you a high advantage.
On the other hand, let's say
if that step itself comes
from a correct solution trace--
maybe there's a
particular step here
which gets a low advantage or
a really negative advantage--
I'm going to just throw it away.
So this is very much reminiscent
of advantage-weighted
regression, except
that here, rather
than doing exponentiated
advantages, which I'm guessing
was covered, we are doing
filtering on advantages.
That's the basic idea.
You can also do
exponentiation of advantages.
So you can train on everything
but multiply the loss by E
to the A. That objective, I
think, requires a lot of tuning.
And if you can only
run one experiment,
you probably prefer
this objective over E
to the A in general.
That's a great question.
So the question is, "Do you
only train up to the good steps
on an incorrect solution?"
The answer is, not really.
So we initially thought
that that's the only way
to train here.
And we did a concrete ablation
studying this as well.
The answer is, well, you never
really train the model to--
so in this particular
setting, you're not--
let's say a particular step
gives you a higher advantage.
You're not training the model
to produce this step and then
this step.
All you're training is to
produce this step conditioned
on the prefix so far.
So your loss looks like
train the model to produce Ai
given Si, and not the previous
actions or the previous steps
that you see up here.
So I'm just going to
probably just draw it here
because I think it's
easiest to draw it.
So think of it as this way--
you had X or S0.
You took A0.
You went to S1.
You are taking, A1, S2.
These are steps, and
this is the states.
Let's say this state
got an advantage which
is really positive.
So A of S1, A1 is really
positive, and A of S0, A0
is really negative.
What you are going
to do now is you're
going to not necessarily--
so what I'm not saying
is train your policy
to produce A0 given S0.
You're not going to do that.
You're going to just train the
policy to produce A1 given S0
comma A0.
So that's all you're trying.
Or I wrote S0, A0.
This basically
just is equal to S1
because you're
concatenating steps.
But that's the thing you're
going to incentivize.
So you're only
training on the steps.
So the question is, "is there
a separate prompter that keeps
prompting the model
when it acts here?"
The answer is not really, right?
So in general, when
you do RL, we never
really train the policy to--
we train a policy to
produce individual actions.
Like, in offline RL or
in imitation learning,
we try to produce A1, given
S1, A2 given S2 and so on.
But when it acts in
the world, it just
acts and produces a giant string
of token-- or giant sequence
of actions in one go.
So you can train the policy
on different segments
of steps it's seeing.
But at when it's
deployed, it's going
to just produce one action.
Then the state S1 is going
to be simply the whole tokens
and the question tokens and the
tokens and the steps so far.
And that's S1, and
you're going to now--
the same policy can now continue
on and produce the next step.
So it's not going to
be prompted in any way.
It's just going to be producing
the whole solution in one flow,
except that now you're
just training it in a way
that you're breaking
them down into steps.
So really, there's no
notion of a separate actor.
So the question is, "Do
you only train on a step
because of the Markov property,
because you don't care how you
got there?"
In a way, the answer is
no, because in some ways,
your state S1 consists
of all of your history.
So S1 consists of--
so S0 is a problem.
A0 is, let's say, step one.
And S1, in this
case, is basically
problem concatenated
with step one.
So in some ways, you have
preserved all of your history
in this case, And it's
a non-Markovian policy
that you're learning, except
that here the reason why
we do this at the step level
is because now we can better
understand which
part of the solution
actually caused me
to derail if it did.
So there's no notion
of independence.
It's not like given S-- so,
OK, in this particular setting,
given S1, sure, action A1 is
all matters, but S1 and S0, A0
are the same.
Depending upon the
way you look at it,
it can be called
non-Markovian policy
as well because it's conditioned
on the whole history.
But in this particular
setting, if you
define S1 as concatenated
states, it's a Markovian policy.
So the question is, "If
your Q value is really--
so the Q values are
really negative,
but your advantages
are positive,
would you put it in the
training data set or not?"
Yeah, that's a great question.
I think we tried this with--
so we did take traces which
were incorrect, and
we put the steps
which were actually good
from them into our data set.
And that was fine,
except that let's
say if there are traces
where everything is just a--
there's no way-- there's no
prefix of that from which you
can succeed at all.
The advantages are also small,
and the [? QL's ?] are also
small.
Turns out that if
you filter them out,
you might do a
little bit better.
But again, I don't have a
very, very concrete like result
I can show you here, so
I'm not going to tell you
that this is the way to go.
But it seems like,
to a large extent,
the sensitivity does
not exist in some way
because the prefix
is the culprit then,
and you're training only a
one conditioned on the prefix
and not training the model
to produce the prefix at all.
OK, great.
So that's the first option.
So this is a lot like
filtered imitation learning
or advantage-weighted
regression.
OK, before that, I can
show you some results here.
So this actually ended up
addressing that error going up
problem, at least to
the extent that we
were able to train models.
So here, again, I'm plotting
the number of correct answers
per question.
And you find that the advantage
filtering did help you,
compared to the RFP approach
which was going up before.
So it does actually--
and we did measure
the number of spurious
steps according
to some heuristic definition
of how we can evaluate this,
how can probe this.
And it seemed like, just from
a qualitative perspective also,
the number of spurious steps
actually reduced in some way.
So
The next thing is,
how can you use
this for offline
reinforcement learning?
And this is where
DPO-based methods come in.
So there was a question about
this earlier in the class.
So you can also use them for--
you can also use
the same principle
for doing DPO actually.
So the idea in DPO is slightly
different from computing
this advantage exactly,
but uses the same protocol
that I described to
you earlier, where
what you're going
to do now is you're
going to take a solution
from your base model
that you're training.
Maybe this is incorrect.
And so far, what we did was we
found out steps that were useful
and retained them in some way
or the other and discarded
everything else.
But what we can do now is
we can do these rollouts.
And rather than throwing away
or throwing away these rollouts
or just using these rollouts
to estimate the advantage, what
I can do is I can, instead,
take a rollout, which ended up
succeeding, with
a shared prefix;
take the solution trace
from my model, which did not
end up succeeding, and construct
a preference pair out of them.
So I now have a preference pair,
which looks like some prefix,
followed by some
correction, which is good,
and some prefix followed by some
steps which are actually wrong.
And I can throw this into a DPR
training data set in some way.
I can also do the same thing
with a correct rollout.
So let's say I have a correct
rollout from my base model.
I can still do these rollouts,
and maybe one of them
will not end up
succeeding potentially
from my rollout policy.
And I can basically put this
thing as a preference pair
into my training mix.
So the nice thing that
is happening-- or there
are two differences
that are happening here.
In some way, I'm still
realizing in this process
that prefixes are shared.
And really, the difference
between a correct
and an incorrect rollout
comes from that little segment
that you see, beyond the
prefix in these settings.
That's the first thing.
And the second thing.
Is, rather than the
previous approach
of filtering by
advantages, I'm actually
retaining the whole
steps that appear
in this rollout distribution.
So I'm not simply
using these rollouts
like the orange-colored, dashed
lines to compute advantages,
but I'm retaining
them, and I'm training
on top of the tokens that
appear in that rollout as well.
So the DPO loss, I guess, I
don't have that on my slides.
But, I guess
probably I don't need
to necessarily write that down.
But it's basically just a
matter of the same old DPO
loss on top of these two
segments of solutions
that we talked about.
Yeah, great question.
So the question is, "Do you
want higher-quality text,
or do you want more diversity?"
I think the true--
OK, I should mention that
this is something that we
have tried to formalize.
So there's an exact equation
that you can write down.
And you can be like OK,
I want a policy to do
these rollouts which maximizes
this expression sort of thing
in one of the papers.
I think that kind of balances,
in some way, diversity
and high quality.
So imagine for a second that
your model is really bad.
So let's say your model mostly
produces incorrect traces.
Then you want a rollout
policy that can actually
somewhat succeed because,
otherwise, there's
no notion of a success that
you can learn from ever.
You've only seen failures.
How can you actually even
learn to solve that problem
if you only see failures?
On the other hand, let's say if
your model is kind of decent,
like 50% accurate, but
it's not as good overall.
It's not the best
at solving problems.
In that case, maybe
all you want is just
diverse ways of
solving the problem,
such that you can see what ways
you're more prone to failing.
So you care about
coverage in some ways.
So really, the answer here is
like every single problem in RL,
there is some balance between
exploration and exploitation
you want to do, which
is high-quality text
or high-quality solutions, which
solve the question correctly
and being more
diverse in some way.
I think the exact
expression for this
is actually something
you can also write down.
And I'm not going
to cover today,
but, yeah, it's a
trade-off between them.
Yeah, so basically
used to train DPO.
So far, I guess--
OK, actually, let me just
write that algorithm down
for everybody's understanding.
So what you do is you're
basically-- so that
is the RFD algorithm.
And now what we're
going to do is
we're going to simply
do the same process.
So for iteration in 1 to
T, I'm going to sample Y1
to N from my current
policy, given any question.
I am going to now
do these rollouts,
so I'm going to do rollouts
and construct the preference
data set Dpref.
In this case, it's
basically those preferences.
And now what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to run or minimize the loss.
That's the main algorithm
that you're going to do.
And the Dpref reef consists
of prefixes generated
from your current base model.
And the trace is
coming from-- one part
of it is from the same model
that you are training pi theta.
The other segment, the other
part of the preference pair
comes from the rollout policy.
That's the orange line.
So the question is, "Given
a sample trajectory,
how we segment into steps?"
So in this work, we
just used sentences.
So we just had
[INAUDIBLE] sentences.
We're going to break
them down into steps
from after every sentence.
In general, I think it depends--
it's a thing that you
can bake into your model.
So if you have played with,
for example, OpenAI models,
you'll see that they
often produce responses
that look like step one in
markdown, like a very big step
one, and then they'll say a
bunch of stuff and then step two
and then say a bunch of stuff
so you can use that notation.
Oftentimes it's so happening
that as these models get better
at basic instruction
following, you
can just prompt them
to produce responses
for complex questions in a
particular stylistic fashion,
and use some heuristics
about that style
to partition things into steps.
So for instance, you
can just tell a model,
well, I want an answer for this
particular question that never
uses the word step,
that always produces
a logical block of calculation,
puts a horizontal line
and then pushes the next
logical block and so on.
And it'll most
likely do it for you,
which is something
you can also do
during the course of training.
So you can just prompt
them to produce solutions
in a particular way and then
define steps accordingly.
There's no universal definition.
So the question is, "Is there
a convention to produce special
tokens for generating steps?"
I think that I've not seen a
very, very clear convention that
is universally
used all the time.
One convention that
we have been using
that I've seen many
other papers use,
but they're still
outliers for this,
is they would produce step hash
1 colon and then say something.
And that could be a
bunch of lines as well.
In this work, we use lines.
In a follow-up thing, we
had used this step notion.
So it really depends on up
to you, really, I think.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
Any questions on the
DPO part in this case?
So this is the DPO
version of the algorithm.
Great.
OK.
So you can do this and
put this into your data.
So if you go back to our plot
from before, if you measure how.
How well does such kind
of an offline RL method
do, what ends up happening is--
OK, I guess, these were supposed
to be GIFs, but anyways.
So I'm now plotting
the test error
as a function of
number of questions
that existed in my data set.
So far, we were
looking at number
of correct answers
per question for a lot
of the plots in the middle.
But now, I'm back
to the plot where
we are plotting the x-axis as a
function of number of questions
in the original data set.
And you find that, compared to--
and now there are
two models here.
One of them is a Llama 2 model.
So this probably it
tells you how old
this work is at this point.
It's a year old, but Llama 2
feels like a long time ago--
and then DeepSeek V2 models,
as well as DeepSeek V2 models.
And what we're finding
in general is that,
compared to the base SFT method,
where you were just training
on human-written solutions,
you can get up to an 8x boost
in the amount of data that
you need for training.
So the dashed line here is
this first-step BPO algorithm
that I talked about.
And you see that it can get
you the same test error with 8x
fewer samples than training
with SFT on human written data.
RFP was 2x for recollection.
I removed that line
here because it
would have been too cluttered.
But in general, this 8x also
holds true for Llama too roughly
overall in this setting.
Yeah, so the question
is, "What is Pass@5?"
That's a great question.
So you can think of Pass@5--
I guess, for
understanding the slide,
it doesn't matter first of all.
But in general, you can think
of Pass@5 basically as saying,
if I gave the
model five chances,
can it succeed even once
out of those five chances?
So it's a way people
evaluate models
because it's telling you that,
OK, maybe the model could not
succeed in one try, but
if I gave it n tries,
maybe it can succeed.
And that's what Pass@n
means in the setting.
I mean, I don't think for
this particular result,
it matters so much.
The main thing to look at is
this 8x boost in data efficiency
that you see up here.
So the high-level
takeaway here is
that if you do offline RL with
this first step notion of credit
assignment that we talked
about, you can actually
get a lot more data
efficiency boost
compared to imitation learning.
So for the same amount of
data, for the same base model--
or sorry, for the same
base model and for 8x fewer
questions, you
can do a similar--
you can get the same performance
with RL in this setting.
Yeah, so, generally,
I've seen people use 0.6
as the temperature for a
lot of the-- so the question
is, "What's the recommended
temperature to use?
I've generally found it to be
0.6 is what most people use.
I don't think that there's
something that's set in stone.
You can always change
it in some ways.
So the question is,
what's a solid line?
That's just SFT on human-written
solutions in this setting.
There's no advantage
in that line.
And the first-step
advantage one was actually
the one I showed to you before.
I removed it here because--
so this is maybe
the ultimate kind
of result in some
ways from human data
to self-generated data sorts.
But yeah, it's like 2x
with the first step.
Yeah.
OK.
So the final thing--
that final main
method, and then I'm
going to just talk about
what people are currently
doing very briefly, and I'll
end the lecture at that point.
But the final thing
we can also do here
is online
reinforcement learning.
There's two ways of doing this.
So the most basic
recipe for doing this
is actually to not use
any of this advantage,
but generalize this kind
of basic RFD algorithm
without advantages to
online [INAUDIBLE].
So how do we do that?
You can basically
just take your model,
similar to how we
sampled a bunch of traces
from my current model
or current policy,
and filtered the right ones.
Rather than filtering, you can
just train it with on-policy RL.
So you can just
generate rollouts
from your current policy, which
might be correct or wrong.
You can reward them
using the reward function
by just checking the
answer against the answer
that the model produces.
You can penalize it if it
does not produce an answer.
You can penalize it
if it violates format.
There's a bunch of
reward-shaping things
you can do.
And then you just
train your policy
to maximize this reward
using policy gradients.
So RFT, we were explicitly
filtering and training with SFT.
But rather than doing this
filtering or training with SFT,
you can simply run
on-policy reinforcement
learning because all
in this formulation
is just state action.
There's an MDP.
There's a reward and
just do r on top of it.
So you can simply write the
policy gradient equation,
so that basically just
looks like grad log
pi times the reward
that you see up here.
And you can just run
that on your problem.
There's also a lot
of work which now
tries to go beyond the basic
reinforce style policy gradient
and goes to methods
like what's called GRPO.
It's nothing but just an
extension of the basic PPO
algorithm in this setting.
So the PPO algorithm--
I guess I'm going
to say a few things.
PPO algorithm uses a
learned value function.
The GRP algorithm replaces
that learned value function
or learned Q-value
function with simply
this rollout-based
estimation of advantages.
So the same old basic
RL recipe applied
on an MDP that looks like the
thing that you see up there.
So a trajectory that looks like
the thing that you see up there
with a 01 reward.
OK.
And what you can
also do-- and this
is something that
finally can do--
is you can also do per-step
advantages in online RL.
That's the final method
that you can apply.
So in this setting you can take
a solution from your base model
or take a solution from
your current policy
that you're training.
Or over the course
of training, you
can do these rollouts
if you want to.
You can use these rollouts
to compute advantages.
And rather than
doing these rollouts,
you can also potentially do
something slightly different,
which is basically to
train a reward model-like
thing to fit to these
advantage predictions
or to fit to these
Q-value predictions
and then compute advantages.
So this is very similar
to some of the RHLF work
that you probably saw,
except that now this
is a reward model that is
rewarding every step of sorts,
or reward model that's producing
the Q-value for every step,
or the advantage
for every step, as
opposed to producing a
reward for the whole sequence
that you're seeing.
And once you have these
advantage predictions
that you can fit to a network,
you can query this particular--
so for any rollout that
your policy produces,
you can query the
advantage predictor
that you have trained to
reward every single step
in this particular
policy generation.
And once you do that,
what you can do now
is you can simply
take your network,
produce these advantage
labels, and optimize for reward
that you're getting at the
end, plus these advantages
that you see up here
in this setting.
Yeah, that's great.
So the question is, "How
generalizable is reasoning?
When you train on MATH,
does it improve on GSM8K?"
So it turns out if
you train on MATH, it
does not improve on GSM8K.
And many people have shown it.
But if you train on a bunch
of mixture of prompts,
which are of varied
levels of difficulty,
you can actually get there.
So this is precisely
the recipe, which
is being used in--
and/or not this one,
but the basic online recipe
which I talked to you about
earlier, used to
train all of these,
or many of these
thinking models which
have open recipe descriptions.
So this online recipe is kind
of used to train the DeepSeek
carbon model, for instance.
And that does generalize to a
fairly good amount of extent.
It doesn't also generalize
to every single problem
out there, but to a fairly
good extent it does.
So you can compute these
advantage predictions.
You can fit them
to a network, use
them to produce these rewards
for every single step.
And that's the more advanced
way of doing online RL
with this particular thing.
So we had a work that we called
process advantage verifiers
here.
A process because it's
rewarding every step;
advantage because it's
fitting an advantage function;
and a verifier because, somehow
in the domain of reasoning,
reward models are referred
to often as verifiers.
So if you see that
word come up, it's
just synonymous to a
reward model of sorts.
Or in this particular
case, even you
can think of it as a Q function
or a value function of sorts.
But that's the
name of the method.
And we find that in general--
so I'm going to skip
some of these details.
But in general, if you
do dense reward RL,
like process reward or
advantage-based reward RL,
you find that you can get
to a much better accuracy,
compared to what's called ORM
model or just 01 one reward RL,
like the sparse 01 reward
provided at the end
of the trajectory.
So this is the basic recipe
that a lot of the current work
is using.
This is the advantage-based
verifiers recipe.
And you can see that
you can get a bigger
boost in sample
efficiency, as well
as in terms of just
absolute performance
that you see up here.
Also, these numbers look small,
but with 2B and 9B models that
we were basing this off of,
apparently this is the best
result that you can get on
certain data sets that we tried
this on.
So it's about 5 or 6x sample
efficiency boost and about 6%
to 7% absolute performance
improvement in this particular
setting with the dense
advantages in some way.
OK, I'm going to skip
some of these things.
But at a high level, we are also
seeing now these newer thinking
models that have come up where
basically these models can just
think for longer and
produce a better answer.
This is the DeepSeek-R1
family of models,
OpenAI family of models or O
series of models from OpenAI.
In my opinion, really,
these are trained
using very similar
recipes that I just
talked to you about
for this whole lecture,
except that there are
some small changes that
happen in this process
from pre these models
versus these models.
So the RL training objective
has remained the same.
So there's some minor details.
Like, there's this
new method called
TRPO which I just describing.
It's basically PPO
with some tweaks.
There's also some other methods
like advantage-induced policy
alignment.
You don't need to know
what those methods are.
Just think of them
roughly as policy
gradient methods done with
slight tweaks overall.
But what has changed is that
the action space in a way
has changed for these
models, in my opinion.
Now, this is a very
crude statement to make.
And to be really
rigorous about it,
I think the statement
sounds wrong
because these models do actually
produce token by token one
at a time.
But these models, the base
models on which we are doing RL,
have become better at being able
to implement interesting meta
procedures.
These models can actually
produce a solution,
maybe go out there and then try
to verify the solution they have
produced, maybe then backtrack
to a particular point
and do something
else from there.
And you can think of this
as just yet another version
of defining the step.
These models can produce
more interesting steps
than just going out there and
calculating yet another quantity
like the models previously
could have done.
So it's just a better notion
of a step or a better action
that these models
can sample when
you run all of these
algorithms on top of them.
And once you do that, and you
give these models a longer
budget to act-- so if you tell
these models that, OK, there's
no limit on how many
tokens you can think,
you can sample during
the course of RL,
you can maybe sample solutions
which are really, really long,
but just get me
the right answer.
If I give these
models that playground
to sample more and
more tokens, turns out
that RL training algorithms
with these two bullet points
actually give you much
better performance.
And that's what we see with
these current thinking models
right now.
It turns out that
these models are--
if you do a counterfactual
experiment where you take models
which are not capable of
implementing like basic
answer-checking or verification
or generating a better answer,
it turns out that you cannot
do good RL with them right now.
So really, nothing
has changed in terms
of the high-level techniques
that I talked about,
except that the base models have
become more interesting in a way
that they can sample interesting
kinds of steps to train on.
And that has led to some
of the most amazing results
that we are seeing right now.